علاقه الصين على لسان المتحدث باسم وزاره
خارجيتها باللومه على قوى ذات دوافع خفيه
ربطه الحريق الهائله الذي ادى الى مقتل
عده اشخاص في منطقه شينج يونج بالقيود
الصارمه التي تفرضها السلطات الصينيه
لمكافحه وباء كوميدي 19
الحاله التي تصفونها لا تعكس حقيقه ما حدث
الصين اتبعت سياسه حيويه تتمثل بصفر كوفيد
واجر التعديلات على اساس الحقائق الموجوده
على الارض
الاجراءات المشدده التي تتبعها الحكومه
كانت المحرك الرئيس للاحتجاجات التي
اندلعت في انحاء مختلفه من البلاد خلال
الايام الماضيه اشتباك محتجون في وقت
متاخر من مساء الاحد مع الشرطه في المركز
التجاري بشانغهاي واعتقلت الشرطه عدد من
الاشخاص ومن بينهم صحفي وكاله رويترز
للانباء قبل ان تفرج عنه بعد حواله 90
دقيقه كما تعدت على احد الصحافي هيئه
الاذاعه البريطانيه اثناء تغطيته الاحتجاج
واعتقلته ثم افرجت عنه بعد عده ساعات
لطالما رحبت الصين بصحفيين الاجانب الذين
ياتون لتغطيه الاحداث واجراء تقارير صحفيه
في الصين وفقا للقوانين المتبعه وقد بذلت
الكثير لتسهيل لتغطيهم وتوفير وسائل
الراحه لهم لكن في الوقت نفسه يتوجب على
الصحفيين الاجانب الالتزام الصارم
بالقوانين والقواعد الصينيه عند القيام
بعملهم في الصين رد فعل الصينيين الغاضب
على قيود مكافحه كورونا يعد انتكاسه لجهود
الصين للقضاء على الفايروس الذي يسجل
اعداد قياسيه من الاصابات ويثير القلق
بشان الخسائر الاقتصاديه لعمليات الاغلاق
في ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم